je vous en parlais l'autre jour je vous
parlais effectivement dû chiens ou des
boîtes sont crus ça commence bien
je vous parlais de celui là le chiot
miller et demi note 9 je vous ai publié
ma vidéo de test dans laquelle je vous
présentais ce smartphone je vous disais
tout je parlais de ses points forts je
parle également de sa faiblesse et je
vous disais que dans quelques jours
j'allais vous parler d'un autre
smartphone c'est le smartphone dont on
parle aujourd'hui justement c'est le
modèle professionnel c'est le show demi
lorraine min 9 pro alors cette année
xiaomi continue sa stratégie d'envahir
le marché de plus en plus dans toutes
les gammes d'avoir des produits à tous
les prix pour tout le monde pour tous
les consommateurs aient autant on avait
il ya quelques années par exemple chez
l'homme il y aurait mille recettes qui
était un super rapport qui a été pris
avec une très grosse autonomie
s'il se retrouve dans la gamme rennes
note autant derrière continuez à mais
plus en plus de plus en plus de modèles
notamment au niveau de la gamme ea le
mil 9009 2009 témoigne à brest on s'y
perd d'ailleurs si vous vous y perdez
vous a fait une vidéo pour vous aider à
mieux comprendre la gamme de chiots me
et trouver le smartphone comité pour
vous trouverez le lien en bas dans la
description est là cette année ils ont
fait le choix au niveau de la gamme rémy
note de rajouter encore plus de produits
on avait un produit maintenant on a
trois c'est une gamme entre et milieu de
gamme
le premier c'est le chiot me doré de
linotte 9 vous avez ensuite le chien au
mirail min 9 s ses modèles
intermédiaires pour parlera un peu plus
tard et là vous avez le modèle le plus
haut de gamme dans cette gamme là c'est
le pro le show me leur éminente neuf
pros autant vous dire que shiomi encore
plus de modèle pour tout le monde et ça
devient encore plus compliqué il s'est
référé de savoir quel modèle réduit note
9 est fait pour vous entre le modèle
normal e s le pro c'est presque la
débandade et tout ça à 50 euros près bon
aujourd'hui on va se recentrer sur le
modèle professionnel qui est le plus
haut de gamme dans l'entrée milieu de
gamme voyons si perd même la com zones
arides un petit peu ça se compliquait
les choses modèle vachement bien et
surtout ce qui est très bien là et je
voulais tout de suite c'est une fois de
plus la question de l'autonomie avec une
grosse batterie de 5000 20 millions
période on a un produit qui est cool on
a un excellent rapport qualité prix à
279 euros 90 dans la version 16 giga de
ram 64 go de stockage
si vous voulez monter en 128 giga de
stockage il vous coûtera un petit peu
moins de 300 euros 299 euros d'un but 90
alors ce modèle là il fait plein de
promesses mais la première chose à
regarder et bien ca
ou est ce qui ressemble est-ce qu'il est
beau est ce que la prise en main est
bonne oui ou non
avant tout vous dire si vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous invite à le faire en
cliquant sur le petit bouton
tu devrais situé juste en dessous vous
cliquer sur s'abonner vous activer la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié vous
saurez tout dès que les prochaines
vidéos arrivent à sa selle rémy note 9
ça c'est leur éminente neuf pros et sur
semble peu ou prou une des premières
grosses différences que vous allez voir
c'est ici vous n'avez pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales alors que là vous
la directive n intégré mais là vous
arrive pas parce que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
ils sont venus le positionner ici sur le
côté ce qui est plutôt bien vous prenez
votre smartphone vous posez votre doigt
et et verrouille immédiatement c'est
très rapide ça marche très très bien
un autre point de différence que vous
avez sur ce modèle là il vous n'aviez
pas sans l'autre là vous avez tout son
parti vert qui est lisse et là vous avez
toute une partie qui est travaillé et
qui nous fait des lignes en fait mon
dans les deux cas on a exactement le
même toucher sauf que en petit imprimés
qui est pas mal qui apporte quelque
chose d'un petit peu différent sinon
c'est quasiment la même chose le bouton
de volume se situe ici il faut savoir
que le modèle pro est un peu plus grand
pas beaucoup mais voyez un tout petit
peu plus grand il est aussi un peu plus
l'eau et fait 10 grammes de plus il pèse
2 109 g et puis voyez il est quand même
très grand on a du mal à faire un tour
avec une seule main c'est quand même un
gros modèles à venir utiliser à demain
on va retrouver de la même manière et si
sa prise usb c'est son haut parleur mono
son micro production bruit sa prise jack
ici son emplacement pour mettre à deux
cartes nanosims plus une carte micro sd
de l'infrarouge le micro pour la
réduction de bruit les quatre caméras
l'arrière ça je voulais dit on a des
morts qui sont assez grands qu'on va
retrouver effectivement sur le bas mais
c'est normal sera introduit dans cette
catégorie là un écran complètement plat
bon ça marche ça c'est cool on va
retrouver ici un écran un peu plus grand
que le modèle neuf de base au lieu
d'avoir un écran de 6 53 pouces vous
avez un 6,67 pouces c'est toujours du
lcd c'est une dalle y ps avec une
résolution de 2400 pixels par 1080
pixels à 396 pixels par pouces un écran
qui est certifié lutter contre la
lumière bleue et que je trouve assez
bien calibré vous pouvez toujours une
affaire quelques petits ajustements ici
dans affichage du couleurs un peu plus
chaude si vous le souhaitez je vous
conseille de rester quand même en
version automatique ici plutôt que
saturé standard venait il réchauffe et
légèrement et puis ça ira très bien
comme ça on n'a pas ici l'écran le plus
mineuse si vous avez en extérieur et
qu'il ya beaucoup de soleil vous risquez
d'avoir quelques difficultés mais pour
venir profiter d'une expérience
multimédia cet écran est plutôt bien la
différence que vous avez aussi avec leur
évidente 9 qui si vous avez le poisson
qui est au milieu tandis que sur notre
modèle votre point son outil sur le côté
pour du visionnage sur youtube ça fait
là faire pour venir jouer à des jeux ça
ira aussi très bien le seul bémol et je
vous l'avais déjà dit avec leur éminente
neuf c'est la partie audio qui est pas
dingue
une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone à moins de 300 euros donc on
peut pas tout avoir vous avez un petit
haut parleur ici un petit haut parleur
mono avec un son un peu mais dionne qui
va avoir tendance à saturer lorsque vous
allez montez le son point positif par
contre si vous avez ici une prise jack
donc vous voyez dire brancher un casque
filaire dessus si vous en avez un
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle et vous
avez également du bluetooth 5.0 si vous
avez un casque que son fils ça irait
également très bien vous pouvez faire
tourner de poésie sans aucun problème
c'est fluide ça marche bien vous aurez
pas la meilleure qualité d'affichage
mais je dirais que pour les expériences
de guémy avec un smartphone milieu de
gamme plein sont bien derrière
et bien ça ira franchement et ça fera
très très très bien le faire le
smartphone répond bien il faut savoir
qu'à une derrière vous avez de la
performance vous avez ici un snapdragon
720 g qui est un soc milieu de gamme
contrairement régnante 9 qui avait un
solde de médiathèque
ici on est chez qualcomm vous êtes
couple et en plus ça si giga de ram et
vous avez choix soit 64 giga de stockage
soit 128 giga et d'ailleurs ici on a le
score sur en tout 260 5508 qui devait
classer entre le p 20 pro de huawei et
le galaxy à 71,2 samsung autant vous
dire qu'en termes de performance vous
avez ce qu'il faut c'est un smartphone
qui est fluide qui répondra bien à vos
besoins on va pas lui demander la lune
mais c'est pas non plus qu'on a cherché
là dessus l'autonomie est externe je les
ai qu une très grosse batterie de 5000
20 millions perreur avec de la charge
rapide 33 watts ou alors les cibles
c'est bien mais dans les faits qu est ce
que ça nous apporter bien ça nous
apporte une bonne autonomie c'est le
point fort de la gamme renmin note ici
vous avez l'autonomie deux jours et demi
alors si vous êtes gourmand aux
gourmandes et que vous lui en demander
beaucoup vous aurez une journée est
guère plus mais si par contre vous y
allez un petit peu modérément avec des
usages standard et bien vous irait
jusqu'à une journée me voir deux jours
avec le smartphone qui surchargent assez
rapidement au niveau de l'eau est sans
tourner sur me why 11 qu'il basait sur
l'android 10 mai un des points aussi
assez important se trouve à l'arrière
puisque vous avez ici pas moins de
quatre caméras alors s'est inversée par
rapport aux ennemis note 9 aux usa au
capteur principal ici il est passé ici
vous avez ici un capteur de 64
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.89 si c'est
un ultra grand-angle
cet ouvrage f 2.2 avec un champ de
vision 219 degrés ici vous avez une
caméra de maquereaux au lieu d'avoir un
capteur de 2 mégapixels vous avez
capteur de 5 mégapixels vous pression ça
change grand chose mais bon là ça et là
tout ça ouvre à f 2.4
il faut bien faire vos photos dans une
distance de 2 à 10 cm ici vous avez un
capteur de 2 mégapixels
l'objectif ouvre à f 2.4 pour le mode
portrait pour les faits bloqués tandis
qu'à l'avant vous avez un capteur de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f/2
points 48
il n'y a pas de grosse différence par
rapport aux renmin note 9 au lieu
d'avoir un capteur de 48 mégapixels sur
la caméra principale vous avez un
capteur de 64 mégapixels
ultra-grand-angle c'est la même chose la
caméra de maquereaux on passe de 2 à 5
mégapixels mais une fois de plus la
macro même avec le capteur de 5
mégapixels bon c'est un peu gadget mais
c'est pas extraordinaire je monte le
résultat en quelques instants et le 2
méga pixels pour le mode portrait pour
l'été boké et bien c'est exactement la
même chose
autant vous dire que la photo ne se
révolutionne pas là dessus
la différence si vous pouvez filmer en
4k jusqu'à 30 images par seconde au lieu
d'un full hd jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde parce qu'on a un processeur plus
performant sur le modèle professionnel
côté selphy très 16 mégapixels dont
voyez pas là il n'y a pas grand chose
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que leurs
ennemis note neuf pros en fait plus que
leur éminente 9 pourquoi parce que c'est
un modèle professionnel tout simplement
ici on est sur le capteur principal
les couleurs sont bien on a une photo de
qualité ça marche très très bien dès
qu'on arrive sur le très grand angle
c'est tout de suite pas terrible d'un
problème de gestion des hautes lumières
la qualité globale est pas
extraordinaire c'est déformant c'est pas
terrible bon là ça envoie un petit peu
passé à côté
dès qu'on arrive dans le zoom x 2 ça
fonctionne également vu koné sur les
capteurs de 64 mégapixels et bien comme
on n'a pas de tels objectifs on vient
zoom est directement 160 4 mégapixels et
le rendu est vraiment très qualitatif et
dès qu'on se rapproche jusqu'à 1 x 10
maximum bon c'est pas terrible ya du
bruit mais une fois de plus sur un
smartphone comme ça c'est complètement
normal caméra principale c'est très bien
l'ultra grand temps que c'est très
imprécis c'est pas extraordinaire x 2
s'écoule caméra principale ça marche on
n'a rien eux cramé dans le ciel on voit
bien tous dans les zones plus sombres en
bas c'est très juste
l'ultra grand temps lien très bien alors
que vous êtes à l'extérieur et que vous
avez beaucoup de lumière mais c'est pas
là dessus qu'on va faire a les
meilleures photos x 200 fonctionne
caméra principale ultra grand angle on
revient la gestion de lumière qui
pâtirait li 6 x 2 ça fonctionne caméra
principale ultra-grand-angle fois de la
macro pour moi c'est très gadget bien
qu'on soit passé sur 1,2 mégapixels mais
sur un capteur de 5
ce n est pas non plus des miracles on
est un peu moins de lumière ici c'est
pas extraordinaire ça devient très pâle
c'est très bruitée alors on a bien
effectivement les faits un peu poil un
peu rigolo mais regardez tout ce qu'on a
à côté c'est vraiment pas extraordinaire
c'est vraiment pour avoir un petit côté
un peu what the fuck mais pas plus que
ça la caméra que celle ci fonctionne pas
trop mal elle a quand même tendance à
beaucoup lycée moi personnellement je
suis pas très fan du traitement le mode
portrait fait le job des tours plutôt
bien il retrouve bien voyons messieurs
au niveau des petits cheveux le mot ne
lui est pas extraordinaire mais c'est
normal on est sur un smartphone coûte un
petit peu moins de 300 euros le rendu
est pas extraordinaire mais ça il
fallait s'y attendre et c'est normal
maintenant la question est est ce que
leurs ennemis note 9 pro est fait pour
vous par rapport aux rémy 29 ou par
rapport au ray min 9 s il est évident
qu'avec leur éminente neuf pros vous
aurez ce qui se fera de mieux notamment
en terme de performance c'est pour moi
la vraie grosse différence qui font
retenir là dessus le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui était
délocalisé du doigt ici bon ok pourquoi
pas mais ça n'a pas bien révolutionner
l'histoire la vraie différence avec la
question de la performance et des jeux
vous allez faire tourner dessus du fait
que vous avez une machine qui ira un peu
plus loin l'autonomie sera bonne dans un
cas comme dans l'autre donc maintenant
la question c'est vous vous par rapport
à votre budget est ce qu'un petit peu
moins de 300 euros
cette machine la passe pour vous ou pas
si c'est le cas bien vous pouvez y aller
parce que c'est un excellent rapport
qualité prix
si ça bloque un petit peu en termes de
budget et qu'on se rapproche davantage
des 200 euros
et bien leur éminente neuf reste une
très très bonne alternative
dans les deux cas je suis remis à une
fois de plus très bien travailler et
rester dans la même idée du meilleur
rapport qualité prix avec la grosse
autonomie là dessus vous aussi savoir
que vous avez du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé ou pour vos pass but ça
marchera parfaitement bien on est donc
sur un smartphone cool que je peux vous
recommander s'il vous intéresse demi des
liens en bas dans la description a vous
de me dire maintenant vous ce que vous
en pensez
comment vous trouvez ce renmin note neuf
pros je me trompe dans les boîtes celle
là leur éminente neuf pros de xiaomi
est-ce qu'il peut vous tentez est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des modèles de chiens
au mythe dans la gamme rémy note donc 9
7 9 99
note 8 pro il ya notre jeu mélange
marquer ma douce ans dans un commentaire
et si vous n'avez pas vu mon test dure
et demi
neuf de nuit et le lien dans la
description comme ça vous serez tout
allait voir voilà maintenant en dvd
demain pas beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]